hey everyone just wanted to give you
some quick channel
updates i'll make this as brief as
possible
so the main thing is you're not really
going to see any more of the vlogs
well at least not unless they involve
tech directly
on code tech tutorials i'm going to move
those to my personal channel
i haven't decided what i'm going to do
with the old ones i might just leave
them up
but i'll send i'll put a link down below
to my personal channel
just for me matthew early so
that way if you are still interested in
seeing my talks and and vlogs and things
about my life
you can do that by just subscribing
there and i'll be posting
all those there in the future so i'm
also working on just ramping up the
production value of some of these videos
and i've also updated my patreon to help
do that
so if you want video credits at the end
of any of these videos
you could do that and just go ahead and
go to the patreon link and sign up for a
one dollar or three dollar tier or
the nine dollar tier and they're all a
different level of shout out but even
the one dollar will still get you
video credits at the end of every new
tutorial
so i've been uh debating with what to do
with this channel
is it about tech is it about code is it
about tutorials and
really it's all three so if i'm making a
video that
is any of those three it's going to go
on this channel
and i think well the thing is
this channel has basically just been me
but i want to make it in a way so that
other people can also do tutorials on
this channel
and i just uh you know host them here
and that way
it's not just me doing all the work and
that way i can
ramp up the production quality a little
bit more
so i thank you all for uh tuning in and
just you know
being loyal followers and all that i
hope you all are doing well leave your
questions and comments down below
and hope you all have a good day peace
out